لا شيء يشغل بالتونسيين هذه الايام سوى
الحديث عن الانتخابات التشريعيه هنا في
احد مقاهي العاصمه الكثيره يتجدد الورواد
المقهى احيانا للساعات حول جدول استحقاق
الانتخابي المرتقب فبين من يؤيد قرار رئيس
قيس سعيد باجراء الانتخابات المبكره وبين
من يرى فيها تكريسا للازمه السياسيه
الحاده ينقسم الشارع
وهناك من لا يبالي اصلا وهم كثر منشغلون
بمتاعب الحياه الكثيره وقد بدت اشد وطئه
مع الارتفاع الكبير في الاسعار والضعف
القدره الشرائيه
الوضع الاجتماعي سيء لبعد العموم
انعكاسات سلبيه وخطيره جدا على الوطن على
الدوله الامام سالم
جدا ايضا فهي اول انتخابات بعد الاستفتاء
على الدستور الجديد والتغيير على بنيه
البرلمان كما تغيب عنها مشاركه معظم
الاحزاب الكبيره والتقليديه
على ما يبدو اكبر الاشكالات هي تتعلق
بالمسار تتعلق بالقانون المنظم تتعلق
بالمشاركه ايضا السياسيه للمترشحين اغلبهم
مترشحين ما هم احزاب سياسيه تعرف اللي
اغلب الاحزاب السياسيه مقاطعه الانتخابات
التشريعيه اما البرلمان الجديد فسيكون
مختلفا في الشكل والبنيه والمهام المنوطه
به فلن تكون على عاتقهم مهمه تعيين رئيس
الحكومه المقبل ولا الرقابه على اعمالها
بل باتت تلك مهام رئيس الجمهوريه وفقا لما
كتب في الدستور الجديد تغيير يرى فيه رئيس
قيس سعيد ومناصره انه يصب في صالح
الديمقراطيه المباشره وترسيخا لمبدا تطبيق
القانون على الجميع فضلا عن قطع الطريق
على الفساد والفاسدين
يارا فارس العربيه